je suis désolé qu'ils frère
désolé de t'avoir embarqué dans cette
histoire je voulais tout redevienne
comme avant
[Musique]
c'est mon frère will tu peux m'aider ma
femme a besoin d'être opéré bienvenue
dans la vraie vie y a pas de justice
quand je pense que tu as risquer ta peau
pour ce pays tu as quitté ta famille ta
maison combien de temps 231 me
un peu plus attiré
32 millions je cherche un gars en plus
je voulais juste emprunté de l'argent
est-ce que j'étais déjà embarqué dans un
truc impossible là tu as l'occasion de
faire quelque chose pour ta famille
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour vous on
est en plein transfert de fonds
souverain qui est j'aimerais bien pas
trop tarder j'ai bientôt fini mon
service je craquerais pas la banque romy
bühler tant mieux ça ferait tâche sur
mon cv crime
[Musique]
allez on se marre vous allez avoir une
super histoire contée hâte après soirée
sur l'échec
huit minutes
en boucle toute la zone
y'a rien qui sort
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous voulez prendre telle
endurance bien faible et c'est que
j'amène à l'hôpital eh bien nous aider
on a besoin de votre aide comprend des
otages maintenant
hors de question de foncer sur cette
ambulance
on a un collègue dedans vous avez une
expérience de secouristes pris aux deux
blessés le coeur vous êtes militaire oui
on fait tout pour vous sauver
une
un
pas de plus et je tiens
métras vous prenez pour un gros dur
calme toi tu as dit
revoir ma femme et mon fils va mais
c'est que vous êtes braqueur de banques
on n'est pas des missions
veux juste rentrer chez nous ce soir
jade s en sortir
on sait tous très bien quand vous êtes
dangereux sans blague
anti tabac aux hélicos tous barrés
je vais être amené à la maison petit
frère fait tous nous ramener à la maison
il
on dit de lui même
je ne suis pas chasseur de primes
on m'a dit le contraire
je sais que vous siégez sur le trône de
votre ancien employeur
tu as baraigne par la peur
j'ai l'intention de renier avec respect
vous étiez jadis capitaine aux ordres de
diama net je viens vous faire une
proposition mutuellement avantageuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi parler de conflits dans la
coopération peut tous nous rendre riche
qu'est ce qui nous empêcherait de vous
tuer
prendre tout ce qu'on souhaite
si vous aviez montré autant d'insolence
envers jabba il vous aurait fait dévorer
par sa petite ménagerie je vous en prie
parler librement
au
bac
pareil
[Applaudissements]
prête serment mourir nc d'agde je jure
de ne jamais dire deux mots qui ne soit
vrai de le fabriquer aucune arme
destinée à tuer
de ne jamais utiliser le pouvoir de
l'unique comme une arme
tu sais ce que veut dire assez
d'ailleurs langues anciennes
ces reventes de tous
[Musique]
ce sont elles qui serge demande
je n'ai pas choisi ce chemin mais je le
suivrai
où allons-nous à deux rivières le sens
ancien cool profondément dans ces
montagnes
espérant que ça les a préparés à ce qui
va déferler
le ténébreux se réveille
il y en aura un qui s'élèvera contre lui
et c'est l'un d'entre eux font
vous avez perdu l'esprit votre vie ne
sera pas celle que vous imaginiez
barrette
qu'est ce que c'est son arme et il
arrive
on nous faire
protéger ceux que nous aimons
quel qu'en soit le prix
miss sont partout
ne laisseront rien sur leur passage
nous avons déjà perdu trop de monde je
refuse de perdre
ça n'arrivera pas
nous n'arrêtons pas le ténébreux
maintenant
entier se consumera
je ne me permettrais pas
la route is comme elle l'entend
tu crois qu'on rentrera un jour
chez nous
non
ah ah ah
[Musique]
oui
faux
passer
d'une femme
ouais
plus fort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces deux grandes magnifique ray il va
falloir trop ça courageux
non
k
ne sera jamais un coran johnny
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
c
[Applaudissements]
comme big thing
gyan de newton
[Musique]
parking
aie aie tina oui
regardez
[Musique]
non
[Rires]
[Musique]
sherlock à la vie apporte au ruisseau
est vraiment génial tout va super bien
j'adore mon nouveau travail je suis le
plus grand pécheur de la planète
après massimo bien sûr
on est comme les pâtes et le pesto je
vais devenir un employé modèle
et massimo sera fier de moi
je pense que ça viendra ciao
[Musique]
bonjour c'est nous les tuons s'apprête à
perdre après on est de retour à
bouzolles travailleurs s'est il
exactement
c'est le moment de préparer noël en
famille mois ce qui se passe devant je
cours et je voudrais que ma soeur soit
il a aussi problème c'est son mari
secours jean roy oui oui ça va vous êtes
chamailler là tous les deux là pour des
conneries il ya dix ans alors au marteau
scène toujours travaillé je me régale
ses magazines tragiquement une pizza
chez matin n'ont jamais livrer une pizza
les fromages pas de pizza trois fromages
deux fois trois ça fait six ans qu'on
voulait
le rabibochage
qu'est ce que je disais déjà devant lui
coûtait pas
on va les voir lucine du père noël
il a pu désigner jouer devant voire des
acquis la gazon marc tous les gros
gagnants les petits meurent vous êtes
dans la deuxième catégorie désolé
je ne proposition à vous faire
voilà mon plan racheter limacher et
fabriquer des jouets hambourg qu'est ce
tu vois un marteau que des clous il
fabrique un jouet que nous n'avons pas
vous pourriez appeler l'inspection du
travail il avait travaillé mais sais tu
ce nom je travaille pas je suis pas trop
vous déjà vu un patron qui travaillent
vous non
c'est les échos tu connais tu connais tu
connais ouais de quoi quoi ah ok j'y
suis les efforts très drôle très drôle
très drôle
[Musique]